on y arrive à paris et moi ce que je
veux c'est qu'on retrouve la courtoisie
auprès des gens qui pensent peut-être un
gouvernement mais qui soit à gérer
nationale aux valeurs de la france à
cette feuille de la république de
l'exception française à faire vacciner
pendant ces deux jours positionnement
soirée
ensuite chacun a sa place en fonction de
ce qu'il ressent des gens qui votent
pour lui doit alimenter la grande baie
james et ses petits ruisseaux qui seront
la grande rivière et ses fruits vous l
esprit de ce début je crois qu'il
commence en france à partir du moment où
les britanniques comme en 40
on nous montrait la voie de la
résistance et montrer que quand on est
debout et bien aussi toujours le cas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]